one of the most prominent peddlers of
critical race theory in the country
ibrahim kendi hoisted himself on his own
pitard over the weekend when he
accidentally tweeted a statistic that
undermined his entire claim of systemic
racism
the lack of racism has gotten so bad in
virginia that supporters of democrat
terry mcauliffe had to send a handful of
fake white supremacists to a campaign
stop for republican glenn younkin as
election day approaches and the
corporate media have declared that let's
go brandon is now officially a nazi
chant
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment friday is from maggie olsen who
says i was talking to an older man at
work about the theft issues and he
straight out said i regret voting for
biden and i will never vote democrat
again it made my heart soar
you know i'm always skeptical of these
sorts of claims because they can sound a
little bit like those things you see on
twitter you know my five-year-old
walking through the tsa said mommy
donald trump is an evil fascist and he
needs to go to jail and everyone
applauded it but when it comes to people
regretting their vote for biden that is
obviously happening you can see that
being reflected in his approval ratings
his poll numbers which are collapsing it
doesn't seem like there's there's really
any bottom to them and it's been
happening since just shortly after the
election so i believe it you get
you get what you
what you ask for be very careful what
you wish for you just might get it now
one thing that you can get right now
which is all upside and no downside
would be
a much better rate on your mortgage so
that's why i would recommend you check
out american financing there is still
time to make a positive impact on your
budget before your end as mortgage rates
remain near money-saving lows now you
might be thinking
why
why my mortgage is fine it's cool well
what you should be asking is how can
your mortgage work for you that answer
can be found at american financing
america's home for home loans they don't
pressure you instead
their salary based mortgage consultants
get to know you so they can lead you to
greater overall savings it could be a
shorter loan term or consolidating debt
there's more to a refinance than just a
lower rate it's the reason why they save
customers up to a thousand dollars a
month why not see what they can do for
you call 800-685-5696
that's
800-685-5696 or visit
americanfinancing.net
nmls18234
nmlsconsumeraccess.org that is
americanfinancing.net you will thank me
later for saving you money not just this
christmas season but well well well into
the future ibram candy oh i love it i
love it when you are
debating a leftist
sometimes the best thing you can do is
just let him talk
if you ju this is this was donald
trump's big problem in that debate with
joe biden is biden was destroying
himself he was undermining all of his
own points but but president trump i
guess had been coached to interrupt a
lot and try to off foot biden and it
didn't if you just let biden talk biden
would have beat himself in the debate he
would have caused himself to lose that's
what kendy did kendy tweeted out
this race hustling con artist ibram
kendy tweeted out quote more than a
third of white students lied about their
race on college applications and about
half of these applicants lied about
being native american more than
three-fourths of these students who lied
about their race were accepted
go on what now what does this mean
for your claim that white people have
all of this privilege in the country and
that there is discrimination in favor of
white people what does that mean if
you're so close to getting it ibrahim
kennedy
but
then he realized he realized he realized
what this means is that there is no such
thing as white privilege in this country
actually there's discrimination against
white people and asian people as well
but notably white people and for some
reason the asians get lumped in with the
whites and so if you apply to college
and you say i'm a white person you are
going to be discriminated against and if
you apply to college and you say i'm a
black person or i'm a native american
person or whatever you are going to be
discriminated in favor of your
application
you're going to receive bonus points
you're going to jump ahead of a white
student or an asian student who have the
same scores and an otherwise similar
resume so ibram kendy realized that he
realized that his whole claim for his
entire
grifting career is bogus and so he
deleted the tweet
then he followed up
because there was a lot of conservatives
jumped on him notably jack posobik was
really just brutal to ebram candy so so
candy follows up he says they lie about
what i said to defend the lying of white
college applicants
no they're not lying they're all we were
just quoting you we were just posting
your screenshot that's not lying that's
exposing exactly what you said verbatim
he said here is their tortured line of
thinking when white applicants think
they have an advantage by lying about
being a person of color then that means
they do have an advantage which then
means that structural racism doesn't
exist nobody you're saying they have the
advantage you said it you said that when
the whites applied and lied about their
race and said they were black and native
american they did better than than
whites who just apply and say that
they're white
you said that
which means you proved that the
so-called structural racism doesn't
exist
and actually it does exist but it
discriminates against whites and against
asians you proved that
jack posobik who is one of the people
most prominently taunting ibram candy on
this point
he tweeted he said hi guys i broke candy
i broke him
he the guy was pushing his stupid
racial theories he's the most prominent
peddler of critical race theory in the
country and then he hoisted himself on
his own petard and then i mocked him a
little and i broke him so then
kendy responds he says a white man it
just goes back to this how dare you how
dare you evil white man criticize me a
con artist who happens to be black a
white man is attacking a black person
with lies which are violent
the black person resists the white man
keeps attacking until he declares he
broke the black person that's the
contest seek a book about slavery
in other words if you make fun of me a
grifting
con artist race hustler on twitter
you are you are no different than us an
enslaver in the antebellum south and i'm
a slave i one of the most lauded fetid
wealthy famous
hucksters in the country
i am no different than a slave
they imagine white people are
disadvantaged while white people are on
the higher end of nearly every racial
disparity they imagine black and native
people have racial advantages at the
same time black and native people are on
the lowest end of nearly every racial
disparity shaking my head okay so
obviously
ibram candy despite his protestations to
the contrary he knows that his first
tweet undermined his entire
thesis he knows that
if he didn't know that if if that first
tweet
did not undermine his hustle
why did he delete it if it was totally
fine and it's oh it's my words are being
twisted people are lying well then why'd
you delete the tweet because you know
that it undermines your thesis
but there is something to this last
point this last point is what allows him
to continue
to push this nonsense and make a
gazillion dollars on his books and his
lectures and shaking down corporate
america and winning all sorts of liberal
prizes
the hustle is permitted to continue
because there are disparities between
racial groups in the country
and white people generally do very well
asians often do a little bit better
asians became white some i don't know
how they became white but they became a
white privilege
it doesn't look like they do but they do
and black people don't do as well and
native americans really don't do as well
okay so what is that what what kendy is
saying is
there are racial disparities in income
in education in
all sorts of things
so how do you explain it if it's not
because the evil white man is keeping
everybody down and he's an oppressive
malignant force in society then how do
you explain it
and there are there are different
explanations for this the libertarians
say it's all about choice
the libertarians say that different
racial groups
on
by and large make different choices when
it comes to different things at
different aspects of society and this
will lead to different social outcomes
the traditionalists say
that
tradition matters that culture matters
that there are these holdovers from
different cultures obviously there are a
whole lot of different cultures in
america and some of them are more
conducive to flourishing in this country
and others are not
the racial essentialists say that people
are just you know entirely different and
it's all biological and it's all in your
dna
so and and what kenny is trying to do is
suggest that if you in any way deny
uh white privilege or you know critical
race theory or any of that then you're
just like an evil vicious racist
bigoted sort of person
but you're coming you're coming at the
question from the wrong perspective then
why why do racial groups do uh do
differently in the country i don't know
it's complicated right because it's
complicated i don't know because
different groups have different
practices they have different traditions
they they come from different places
there are different historical
circumstances i'm willing to grant all
of that okay
but the fact remains that when the white
kids lied about their race and pretended
to be from the other allegedly
disadvantaged races they got an
advantage
which means that the structural legal
racism that you're talking about
does not exist as you say it does and
actually it exists in the other
direction
and so if ibram candy really wants to
figure out why there are social problems
in the country you need to look
somewhere else
look to fatherlessness look to certain
social pathologies
look to these issues
if you actually want to solve that
problem but ibram kenny doesn't want to
solve that problem ibram candy wants to
keep making a couple buck a couple bucks
but more than a couple bucks really by
shaking down guilty white liberals and
and hustling them at their corporations
and their schools and their local
governments and he's making a lot of
money doing it he's making a big name
for himself but he's not he's obviously
not solving any
problems
okay they've got to invent
the white the white racists
the whites the evil white supremacists
who allegedly run this country they have
to invent them they don't exist
how many of them are there like
like three they don't they don't exist
and so
right now there's a tight race in
virginia we're going to know the results
of that why
we're going to have the election
tomorrow i don't know when we're going
to know the results these days sometimes
it takes weeks to know the results of an
election because we're descending into a
third world tin pot dictatorship but
the election is going to happen tomorrow
and you've got the democrat terry
mcauliffe who's a crooked clinton
corrupt guy and then you've got the
republican glenn younkin
so glenn young he's a moderate
republican
he's running a relatively moderate race
but he's doing well
he's doing well on this issue of schools
and it's hard to paint him as a white
supremacist and a nazi and a trumpy and
this and that
so the democrats
sent
fake white supremacists to his campaign
rally
dressed up they dressed him up like the
guys from charlottesville with the tiki
torches and the white shirts and the
khakis
and you know if it had been if this were
100 years ago they would have sent him
wearing clan robes
but
now they're sending them dressed up like
the charlottesville people and it was
all
fake it was all
a political
operation
now when you want to
[Music]
really work yourself up not just work up
your mind and get your blood pumping
because of how crazy politics is but
because you're actually engaging in
physical activity would strongly
recommend you check out echelon when you
are trying to reach your fitness goals
it can really help to have world-class
instructors choreographing classes music
from your favorite artists and a
community of hundreds of thousands of
people who can give you that extra push
now that's generally hard to bring into
your house i don't know how big your
house is but it's hard to bring those
hundreds of thousands of people to your
home
echelon is the affordable way to get the
workout equipment
and the workout community and the
instructor's motivation right in the
comfort of your own home echelon's
fitness app provides you thousands of
live and on-demand classes with great
music with echelon you can work out
anytime day or night and crush your
fitness goals echelon's full range of
affordable workout equipment including
stationary bike smart rowers sleek
fitness screens
and the auto folding treadmill are all
connected to provide the echelon
experience around the clock classes for
the family including full body workout
programs that keep you coming back one
membership covers a family of five right
now for a limited time our listeners get
up to eight hundred dollars off msrp to
get this exclusive podcast discount text
knolls to 81 81 81 text knowles k wles
81 81 81 to get up to 800 off msrp that
is knowles kwles 281
8181 at the glen yonkin rally we're in
the final stretch now it's where just
one day before the the election
a group of people show up to the glen
yunken event dressed up like the tiki
torch people from from charlottesville
the left-wing media ran with this and
they said look at the kind of people
that glenn youngkin is attracting he's a
nazi he's a white supremacist you know
the same thing that they say about
literally any republican who gets close
to winning any republican could be dog
it's just trump oh no it's just
glenn younkin oh it's just mitt romney
oh it's just john mccain you're just
whoever it is they've been doing it they
did it to reagan they did it to buckley
they've been doing it forever any
republican who gets close to winning
they call a nazi and a racist and a
supremacist and whatever so they do this
the left wing out let's run run with
this but conservatives just knew it was
bogus
because we just we
while some libs there are some
i think
malevolent libs who are intending to
deceive people on this but i think a lot
of libs just don't know they believe
what they hear on cnn and msnbc they
really believe that republicans are
members of the clan and so when they see
a bunch of
white supremacists show up to a
republican rally they just say of course
that's what happens
and it's it's almost always a hoax
if not every single time a hoax but
because the libs live in that bubble
they just assume it's true
and so the republicans and the
conservatives we knew the minute we saw
this we said this is fake it's just not
this just isn't real they were sent by
the democrats and so it took about five
minutes and everyone starts googling and
we find out oh yeah
yeah they're just democrat operatives
and
so some people identified actually the
specific people in
the group of five or six people who
showed up to the younken rally
he said oh yeah so and so is the
treasurer of the local democrat party
and so and so works for this democrat
operative and so and so and all of a
sudden all these people
locked their twitter accounts and they
went on lockdown so shortly after that
the lincoln project took responsibility
the lincoln project is a bunch of
ex-republicans they're ex-republican
operatives so they were kind of paid
guns and they couldn't get hired anymore
by republicans so then they became
democrat operatives and this is guys
like um stuart what's his name stuart
stevens is that yeah
this is guys like um
like rick wilson these guys like george
conway this is guys like john weaver who
turned out to be a pederast and got got
the lincoln project in a whole lot of
trouble because he was using his
political position to try to groom young
boys for sex so the lincoln project you
know not the most reputable group on the
left they took responsibility for this
i will say
one area i think conservatives
went a little wrong in their reaction is
the conservatives believed that the
lincoln project intended to deceive
people and make make out that these were
actually white supremacists i don't
think that's what happened
i don't think that's what happened at
all i mean the first of all one of the
people they sent was a woman dressed up
like a man and you know it was like a
little blonde girl and another person
they sent was a black guy
dressed up like a white supremacist so i
don't look
i guess it's possible that the lincoln
project
operatives are this or the stupidest
people on the face of the earth it is
possible but i think what they were
doing is they were sending them there as
a protest to make a point and then the
liberal media very gullible and stupid
misinterpreted that and ran with it and
said they were actually white
supremacists regardless what whatever
the the lincoln project took credit
they said
uh
the lincoln project has run
advertisements highlighting the hate
unleashed in charlottesville as well as
glenn younkin's continued failure to
denounce donald trump's very fine people
on both sides we will continue to draw
this contrast in broadcast videos on our
social media platforms and at yonkin
rally so
today's demonstration was our way of
reminding virginians what happened in
charlottesville four years ago the
republican party has embraced those
values and glenn younkin's failure to
condemn it so
if he will denounce trump's assertion
that the charlottesville writers
possessed very fine qualities he will
withdraw the tiki torches until then
we'll be back so the lincoln project
gets called out the whole stunt
backfires so they say well this is all
because
donald trump called nazis and white
supremacists very fine people at
charlottesville this is
the same
canard with which donald trump with
which joe biden rather began his 2020
presidential campaign don it was the
very first thing in his very first
campaign address
donald trump called nazis and white
supremacists very fine people at
charlottesville
the problem with that assertion and that
justification for this stunt
is it it never happened it is tuck that
away with the easter bunny and the tooth
fairy it is completely imaginary it is
such a joke it is such a hoax that even
jake tapper whom i don't really like and
i think he's a big lib and not very
honest a lot of the time and very
favorable to dems and not
almost ever favorable to republicans he
on cnn
even he on cnn
admitted that it was a bunch of baloney
let's uh play some of the sound of
president trump back in 2017 saying he
had said today that he answered the
question uh perfectly uh let's take a
listen
[Music]
they showed up in star wars excuse me
and you had some very bad people in that
group but you also had people that were
very fine people on both sides
now elsewhere in those remarks the
president did condemn neo-nazis and
white supremacists so he's not saying
that the neo-nazis and white
supremacists are very fine people
so he's not saying
that the neo-nazis and the white
supremacists are very fond of people
trump said then i'm not talking about
the neo-nazism white supremacists they
should be condemned totally
you've heard it
only really from conservative media
and occasionally someone like jake
tapper gets a pang of conscience and
says look guys come on
come on you can't push this lie but that
that's the lie and that will be used to
justify all of these other deceptions to
send fake racists into places because
the real alleged white racists they just
they just don't really exist
okay in the alleged structural racism in
favor of white people it just doesn't
exist
it's just it's fake and
jake tapper will admit it and ibram
candy will accidentally admit it
sometimes but he'll delete it when he
does what the lincoln project stunt says
to me
what it proves to me beyond the racial
stuff or the yunkan campaign
is it reminds me that the left can't
meme
they can't meme they don't know how to
meme
when i say meme
i'm referring to
the kind of organic
funny
effective
substantive
jokes
criticisms
political stunts
that proliferate mostly around the
internet but sometimes in real life too
the left can't do that
give you a great example of one of these
a southwest airlines pilot was just just
touched down you know came over the
loudspeaker hey there welcome everybody
we've gotten to our donation destination
rather and uh he finished his
announcement
with those three beautiful words that
have gone viral in this country
let's go
brandon seven or eight miles an hour
good visibility mostly clear skies 77
degrees
thanks for coming out flying the
southwest airlines welcome over and
remember
and remember let's go brandon
so this is this is the welcome over this
is the uh announcement at the beginning
of the flight let's hey let's go brandon
what does let's go brandon mean let's go
brandon is a meme
that stands in for f joe biden because
crowds at stadiums all around the
country have been chanting f joe biden f
joe biden and one time some sports
reporter was talking to a guy named
brandon on a racetrack and she didn't
want to acknowledge that they were all
chanting f joe biden so she said oh you
can hear them brandon they're saying
let's go brandon so now the right has
adopted this phrase let's go brandon and
it's gone viral again
and the left is so
so angry about this meme uh tristan
snell
who is an msnbc and cnn commentator
tweeted out quote let's go brandon has
become the maga version of zig hyle
if you say let's go brandon you're a
nazi wow
wow that's what an original thought
that's really
what a what a powerful and profound
statement tristan snell that really
makes me think about this issue in a new
and interesting way doesn't it
you're calling your opponents nazis wow
i've never
it's never occurred to me to do that wow
oh my
goodness the left can't meme
what's funny too they're saying that
let's go brandon is vulgar it's not it's
it's the opposite of vulgar
f joe biden is vulgar let's go brandon
is no it's it's
devulgarizing
the
statement that a lot of people are
feeling it's clever it's funny it's
really funny and the fact that you get
so angry about it makes it funnier
and you're gonna get more of it because
you guys get so upset this is the same
group that shrieked profanities for four
years straight over over donald trump
and called him all the nastiest
filthiest names in the book but the
minute we make a little clever joke
let's go brandon they say this is it's
your nazis it's like sig hail why can't
the left mean
there is a simple answer to this i'm not
just sort of spiking the football and
saying haha we're funny and they're not
funny and
there's a
real political reason why the left can't
mean the left can't meme because they
are the ruling class right they control
everything they control the government
and the media and the schools and the
tech platforms and the money and wall
street and everything and they control
all of it
and so they can't meme because a meme is
in practice a subversive
funny way to criticize and undermine the
ruling class and they're not going to do
that to themselves they already control
everything and that is why just at a
practical level
as long as the democrats continue to
rule in this country
the memes the the memes of production
are going to be owned by the
conservatives
now
the democrat rule has not panned out
very well
you'll probably see this when you go to
the pump because gas is going through
the roof which is why i recommend you
check out
get upside get upside has arrived right
in the nick of time it is this
incredible app that you need to know
about if you ever buy gas which i assume
is statistically all of you
our listeners are making up to 25 cents
for every gallon of gas every time they
fill up you just download the free get
upside app in the app store or google
play right now use promo code knowles kw
las get a bonus 25 cents per gallon on
your first fill up
that's up to 50 cents cash back do not
pay full price at the pump anymore get
cash back using get upside down load the
app for free use promo code knowles
canada wles to get up to 50 cents per
gallon cash back on your first tank
some people who drive a lot are making
as much as two to three hundred dollars
a month in cash back there's no catch
the cash back gets added right to your
bank account you can cash out any time
to your bank account paypal or an e-gift
card for amazon and other brands just
download the free get upside app use
promo code knowles k wles to get up to
50 cents per gallon cash back on your
first tank what's that code
canadawles you can thank me later
tomorrow night your very own native
virginian resident matt walsh is going
to sit back and watch election results
in an exciting real-time live stream
come watch with matt over at
dailywire.com at 7 30 pm eastern 6 30
central if you want to stay in the loop
on more breaking news from daily wire
join now a membership is as little as
four bucks a month and you can get 25
off now using code real news join today
watch with us tomorrow night at
we'll be right back with a lot more
president trump
just showed up to the world series
and one of the memes that's going around
the world series one of the memes that
goes around the braves
is the chop
you know sort of indian chop so the
braves fans were doing this and
president trump joined in on the fun
i love they're all doing it and there's
trump there right in his box
doing that you can hear people down
below is that mark meadows yeah it is
you can hear people down below he's
doing it too look he's doing it too
so the left can't do this they're not
allowed
to do this
okay and we can why isn't the left
allowed to do because they would be told
this is racist
this is a racist to
do a thing that is associated with
indian culture you can't do that it's
the braves and you're not you can't
trump is not from georgia
i don't think trump even likes georgia
that much because he thinks that georgia
was rigged and took the election away
from him
trump's a new yorker so why is he there
rooting for the braves because the
braves
are
they're the politically incorrect team
right now they've got the politically
incorrect name
they're in georgia which which has those
politically incorrect laws
pro-life laws all sorts of laws and
that's why mlb took the all-star game
out of georgia but now they've got to go
back for the world series that's
hilarious
and so we get to smile and laugh and
have fun and do the the indian shop
why because we're not the ones taking
away people's baseball
and teams
and culture
and fun
we're not the ones doing that we
conservatives are saying no you should
have your baseball teams and the names
and you should have your fun and you
should have your culture and you can
wear a sombrero on cinco de mayo and you
should be able to wave the american flag
and you should be able to have your
families and you should be able to make
jokes
and you should be able to have your
country
and the left is saying no your country
is evil
it's awful
especially if you're a white or a man or
straight you're really bad
and so they're they're this party of
scolds
and the right is having fun now
it's it's unfortunate in a way because
the reason we're having fun is because
we're not ruling we're not in power
right now
but that does that that is a kind of
power in and of itself the power to
weaken the regime to criticize it to get
a lot of other people around to
criticize it that
is
helpful it's almost undeniable at this
point
that the left is the ruling power in
this country
even left-wing
outlets are recognizing this
there there was a headline in the nation
the nation is a pretty
pretty far-left magazine as far as
mainstream magazines go the nation is
about as far left as it gets
and the headline is from david bromwich
is this david bromwich the professor
this might be
i don't know i can't say i don't it
doesn't have his bio at the end
yes he is david brown he's a professor
of mine actually in college that's kind
of funny he's a bit he's a liberal guy
and
the headline is have democrats become
the party of the rich
if you're waiting for democrats to talk
as frankly about wealth as they do about
race don't hold your breath have they
become the party of the rich duh
duh of course they have and and here's a
there's a line quote
some recent u.s figures on the
distribution of income by party 65 of
taxpayer households that earn more than
half a million dollars per year are now
in democrat districts 65 of them
74 of the households in republican
districts
earn less than 100 000 per year
right and yet when i was growing up
there was this idea that republicans
were the party of the rich democrats
were the party of the poor the working
class
the reality is not that that is not the
case
but conservatives did make a big mistake
conservatives have spent much of my
lifetime shilling for mega-corporations
who hate our way of life who have
nothing but contempt for the american
people and who have no loyalty to our
country
and will sell out our country and
undermine the first chance
that they get
conservatives obsession
with economics
has made us politically impotent
the the fact that we constantly have to
campaign i mean we don't really do it
anymore but we used to just campaign all
the time on tax cuts for bill gates and
jeff bezos we it is so important to the
american system
that super woke democrats need to pay
even less in taxes
we need to make sure that nike pays less
in taxes
why
but we need to
they defend facebook they defend twitter
they defend google free enterprise
demands that we let google a radical
left corporation
control all of our speech
and censor the dually elected sitting
president of the united states when he's
republican
and all the rest of it i don't think
that's true
i was in a debate recently on tv on fox
la with a democrat guy and he said
he was going on and on about the
the push to raise taxes i said good
raise taxes i don't care raise taxes on
the rich it's fine by me probably won't
do that great for the economy but
whatever if you're going to make rich
democrats pay more money
fine i don't
let him let him eat the rich for all i
care
he's a rich who disproportionately
democrats and he was kind of flummoxed
by that what we need to recognize
is that our battle here is cultural not
just economic you know i'm going to the
national conservatism conference i was
supposed to be there today
but i couldn't couldn't get away from
the studio in times i'm going to go
tomorrow a really great event if you're
in orlando come check it out
euromasony's putting it on a really
really sharp philosopher
today
so we're all trying to work out what
does it mean what does national
conservatism mean what is what is the
winning conservative message moving
forward marco rubio is one of the people
who is kind of working on this he's
trying to buck older talking points but
sometimes he stumbles and i feel he
stumbled in recent days rubio came out
against the the biden budget this
multi-trillion dollar awful budget and
and he said the problem with this budget
is that it's not going to build us back
better it's going to build us back
socialist
so we've all been following the
democrats inter-party drama over biden's
spending plan for america but in the end
you know we're going to hear today that
they've got some kind of a deal look
unfortunately the media the way they're
going to report it is not what it is
the whole focus is going to be on the
fake top line number right the squad
wanted seven trillion dollars the
democratic budget said 3.5 trillion
dollars but today the deal whether it's
1.5 or 1.75 or 2 trillion dollars it
doesn't matter it's still socialism it's
still build back socialism
the media and the pundits are going to
claim that this proves that biden is
this great deal maker bridging the
divide between the big government
socialists and the huge government
socialists
so it's going to fall on those of us who
know the truth and see this plan for
what it is to inform you the american
people
this plan is not built back better as i
said this plan is to build back
socialists
ah man i uh
you know i like rubio and i like i like
that he's trying to mix it up a little
bit in conservatism i like that he's
opposing this budget i hate this budget
but
this is
as the kids say
cringe socialism it's socialism it's so
everything i don't like is socialism i
don't look that democrats have embraced
socialism and socialism is evil
yeah it is it is evil
the great fight of our age
is not between socialism and capitalism
capitalism a word that was popularized
by karl marx by the way people forget
that
it's not it's not between socialism and
capitalism it is between
barbarism
and civilization
that's the fight it's not about
economics get this through your heads
people
it is not about economics it is not
about tax rates it's not even primarily
about the national debt or government
spending it's
it is about those things downstream
those those things are symptoms
of a bigger problem but the problem does
not stem from
bean counting on a spreadsheet
the problem stems
from cultural issues
okay
we have right now
a
racial caste system being implemented in
this country where prominent figures in
this country are claiming that white
people are evil and need to be abolished
and need to be punished along with
asians for whatever reason in university
admissions and in jobs and elsewhere
okay we are living in a country right
now where little boys little children
are being taught that boys can be girls
and girls can be boys and they should
mutilate their genitals when they're
little kids so that they can pretend to
be the other sex
and you're talking to me about higher
tax rates
or more government spending that's not
the problem okay and
this came up during the tea party
i remember i was in those fights i was
working campaigns during those fights
and everyone thought if we just get the
the debt in order if we just get taxes
and we're taxed enough already you
remember that t
t e a taxed enough already if we just
get this economics focused message
and don't really care about any of the
social or cultural issues it'll all be
totally fine and then we'll get the
country back on track
we won't deal we'll have a cultural
truce
we'll deal with the numbers and then
we'll fix the the culture and it didn't
work it failed it totally failed
valiant effort
i see why people thought it might work
it didn't
the deeper issues
open borders immigration assimilation
what america even stands for protests of
the american flag racial divisions which
deepened and deep into deepened in
recent years
sexual confusion which has only gotten
worse
that has has left us so confused as to
who we are as a country
we don't even know what end is up and
you're not going to fix the fix the
economic stuff until you fix the
cultural stuff
it's not it's
really
it's a real boomer energy
to pretend that this is
1978 and we're just it in the cold war
okay and it's all just about
socialism versus capitalism it's not
back in those days we had far greater
national unity we we agreed on way more
stuff now we don't agree on what a man
is or what a woman is okay and she gotta
fix that stuff first listen to your
voters people listen to
the only great you want to talk about
the tea party listen to the only
grassroots movement
that is helping conservatives and
republicans right now and that may throw
a republican the governorship in
virginia
it's this issue of the schools and
specifically it's critical race theory
and the transgender stuff
there was a woman who showed up in
loudoun county where a lot of this is
being focused showed up to her school
board
and mentioned that her daughter asked
this white woman the daughter white girl
asked her mother if she was born evil
because of the color of her skin
my children are now in private school
and are thriving we had specifically
moved into based out of lcps due to the
swift and uncompromising political
agenda of superintendents williams
ziegler and sk and the school board
that have forced upon us first it was in
early spring of 2020 when my
six-year-old somberly came to me and
asked me if she was born evil because
she was a white person something she
learned in a history lesson at school
then you kept the schools closed for a
year and a half despite the science
indicating that it was safe for kids to
return and now you've covered up a rape
then arrested humiliated and falsely
accused her parents of being domestic
terrorists i wish i could return my kids
to lcps private schools expensive and i
want my kids to be able to walk home
from school with their friends in their
own community
i refuse to allow you to destroy our
schools they are not your schools they
are our schools you all should be
ashamed and you should have the moral
courage to admit you are wrong and step
down
preach sister absolutely right such
moral clarity and she's very articulate
as well
this matters much more to americans than
tax cuts do
i like tax cuts i don't like paying a
lot of taxes i want to pay the lowest
amount of taxes that i am legally
obligated to pay okay but if my taxes go
up a little bit
i'm like probably not even going to
notice
right or i'll notice a little bit and
it's too bad and
we won't go out to dinner a few times
that year and but it'll be fine you know
what i really care about
my kids being taught that they're born
evil because of the color of their skin
you know what i really care about my kid
being pumped full of insane sexual
confusion that could ruin his life that
bothers me i can't send my kids to
public school
that bothers me
i wish i could send my kids to public
school
but i can't i went to public school my
wife went to public school we met in
public school
i have no problem with that
i really like public schools
where i liked them
and even then our schools were very very
liberal but
they weren't mutilating kids genitals
all right they weren't pumping their
heads full of this racial nonsense
that says you're evil if you're a white
person
that's a big problem it's a big problem
for people i like to think hopefully
look hopefully i sell some more blank
books i can afford to send my kid to
private school even though by the way a
lot of the private schools are pretty
bad too
or maybe we can homeschool
i hope we have the resources to do that
when the time comes i don't know what i
do know is that for most americans they
don't really have the resources to do
that or it's very very difficult for
them to
focus on that
let's let's focus a little bit more on
that i know it's a little politically
edgier and riskier to talk about things
like race and sex
than it is to talk about tax cuts and
socialism and government spending
but those are the issues that matter to
people those are the issues where the
left has gained a huge advantage and
it's deeply unjust and it's wrong for
everybody and you should fight back
especially when the people who are
peddling this have have nothing but
contempt for their constituents there
was a school board
a woman just another woman or women of
all shapes and colors and sizes and
demographics showing up to these school
boards to say don't teach my kids this
crap
one of the school board presidents
actually uh
she used a phrase similar to let's go
brandon but the right we use the kind of
nice devulgarized version this woman
just used
the the
insults and the swear words themselves a
california school board president
was listening to this woman
opposing the vaccine mandates
for the little kids
who are at very very low risk of
coronavirus
who
really
should i think the parents should be
allowed to make these medical decisions
for themselves
and the school board president heard her
out then cut her off the earliest chance
she got and then said f you lady my name
is lauren napoli and i am here as a
concerned parent to urge you to be the
first school to say no mandates for our
children let our children leave our
children alone let them be kids and
enjoy one another let them breathe again
and smile again emailing and calling
like you say isn't going to help choose
your own path scott choose your own path
that was very rude to you to say thank
you your parents are selfish you say
favorite snacks thank you your time's up
but you can hear it
pretty pretty clearly because we're a
family show
you see the school board members
when they're talking about little kids
education they can use whatever nasty
language they want but we hear on this
show we try to keep it a little a little
more wholesome
these people hold you in contempt they
hate you they think that you're a racist
an a phobe an a hateful bigoted person
they think you're born evil
whether you're white or whether you're
not white but you agree with
conservatives then you just sort of
become white you know then
i don't know you're like that guy that
the lincoln project sent to to the terry
uh to the glen yunkan event rather
maybe you look black or like a some
other minority but you're a white
supremacist if you support these
conservatives or you show up to these
school boards or you say don't don't
tell little johnny that he's a really
little jane you're an evil or don't
judge people on the color of their skin
you're an evil deplorable bitter
clinging bible-thumping idiot rube who
just needs to die off
and make room for the good better
americans okay
this is a big problem for terry
mcauliffe who's the former governor of
virginia who wants to be the governor
again
the democrat there whose campaign is
tanking because of the issue of
education he came out and said that
parents should not have a right
to say anything about their kids
education that the education should be
run by the teachers and the
administrators and the politicians and
that this is true from preschool up
until you graduate so we're talking
about what it does in you more than a
dozen years
and this is really hurting his numbers
so
so he goes on msnbc he says it isn't
true i'm being taken out of context and
by the way you're all worried about
critical race theory critical race
theory is not even being taught
in virginia schools
what's glenn younkin's education plan he
wants to ban critical race theory well
let me explain it it's never been taught
in virginia okay so now now terry
mcauliffe is going back to this thing
it's not being taught
critical race theory it's just something
at harvard law school it's not being
taught in our schools
now that's not true there were a number
of documents on the virginia department
of education website referencing
critical race theory explicitly
and
uh
beyond that we just know that this is
being taught
in the schools i mean we've we've we've
seen lesson plans from all over the
country and we've seen the democrats
waffle on their arguments here first
they said well first they were pushing
critical race theory then christopher
ruffo led the charge and then all the
conservatives called it out then the
democrats had critical race theories not
being taught in schools
and now then after that you saw
when we can prove that it's being taught
in schools and you can just go to the
virginia department of education website
then you saw the democrats go back and
say actually critical race theory is
really really good and it should be
taught and critical race theory is great
and huge education lobbies and national
organizations are saying you know it's
good and we're going to keep teaching it
but now that's hurting their numbers
still so now terry mcauliffe is going
back to the other strategy and saying no
critical race theory is not being taught
in the schools
it's it's like dr fauci's do you
remember dr fatchi's denial when he
perjured himself to rand paul rand paul
said are you you're doing gain of
function research
and and dr fashion said we have never
done
any gain of function research
and it was totally fine when we did it
uh um
those two
uh those contradict one another
well it's the same thing here critical
race theory
is not being taught in schools and it's
wonderful and students should continue
to learn it
well you to pick one
this is the nearest thing to another tea
party i have seen
since 2010 or 2011. i was speaking with
kara mckinney on oan
and she
she called it out
explicitly
so this is kind of the new tea party
i've been calling it the crt party it's
the cr this is
what what
made the tea party different than a lot
of
political operations is that it really
was largely grassroots
there really were people who just
ordinary people who showed up and they
had 20 bucks to donate and they had
their gadsden flag and they
they were defending
their view of american constitutionalism
and specifically this economic focus get
rid of the debt
you know stop all this crazy spending
cut taxes that sort of thing
this is the nearest i've seen to that
uniting people all around the country
around a real issue that republicans
have not paid a lot of attention to
forcing the republican party to start
paying attention to it
and it's all coming to a head in
virginia and we'll find out what happens
we won't know by tomorrow's show we'll
know by wednesday's show
but we'll see what happens regina's very
blue commonwealth
and so terry mcauliffe should walk away
with this race
but glenn juncken is putting up a real
fight and now in some of the polls glenn
juncken is up actually the republican is
up
i think it's very important that glenn
young can win this race
not because then the republicans can do
x y or z glenn young it's kind of
moderate i think it's very important
that glenn young can win this race
because all the indicators show that he
really could win this race and if he
wins this race
it will defend the legitimacy of the
american system
right now a lot of republicans
are doubtful that the american system is
legit
okay the democrats changed all the
election rules during covid they put
them all to their advantage we can't
count our ballots on election night
anymore for some reason it's taking
weeks and weeks and weeks until
democrats find more votes and then they
can say okay we won
and the the left in this country hasn't
trusted elections in 20 years right they
still terry mcauliffe still denies the
results of the 2000 presidential
election still denies the results of the
2018 georgia gubernatorial election on
the campaign trail this year in the year
of our lord 2021 and republicans have a
far greater reason to doubt the
credibility of the 2020 election because
they changed all the rules right before
it
to their own advantage to the democrats
advantage i think it's very important i
think if glenn younkin
i think if terry mcauliffe comes out
ahead
in the virginia election i think it's
going to
continue the united states down this
path of not trusting our system this
path toward tin pot dictatorship if
terry arif glen yunken rather can pull
it out
and is named the governor after this i
think it would bring the temperature
down a whole lot and give everybody a
fighting chance to preserve this system
we'll just have to wait and see i'm
michael nolan's the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
bori our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021 on
the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show